hey everyone Jared here today we've got
a special episode about a special show
Rick and Morty
every episode is chock-full of
references to sci-fi horror and fantasy
from the aliens to the premises it's
like the purge Morty that that movie the
purge to the gadgets the list is endless
while many of these references are
throwaway jokes or simple homage others
can be quite thought-provoking and
insightful by observing how Rick and
Morty inverts common cliches and tropes
we can better understand one of the
smartest shows on television and why we
love it so much welcome to this special
wisecrack edition on references in Rick
and Morty by the way this is a slightly
different format from how we've done
things in the past so if you like it let
us know what you think in the comments
the devil comes to town in the episode
something Rick AddThis way comes
Rick and Morty uses the arrival of Satan
to turn the idea of deal with the devil
on its head the episode title comes from
Ray Bradbury's Something Wicked This Way
Comes a novel about some weird carnies
with a magical carousel that enables
people to become younger or older at
will of course there's a catch
and anybody who benefits from this magic
also becomes beholden to the evil of the
carnival making deals with creepy
strangers is also a theme in Stephen
King's novel needful things which
surprise is the name of the devil's shop
of oddities in Rick and Morty in the
book people are tricked into buying
garbage that appears to be rare or
valuable at a very low cost the catch in
exchange for a great deal you must play
a few pranks on your neighbors that end
up throwing the town into a kind of
Civil War in Rick and Morty the devil
opens up a shop where the items are free
but also creatively ruin whatever
benefit one hopes to receive Rick gets a
magic microscope that will make him too
stupid to use it
Morty's math teacher gets an after shape
that attracts women but also makes him
impotent stories about making a deal
with the devil often reflect the hidden
consequences that result from trying to
thwart the natural order of things in
order to fulfill your selfish desires in
good Rick and Morty fashion the show
takes this moral refrain and throws it
in the toilet
counteract the negative effects in
Rick's version of story
you can have everything you want because
science it detects and catalogues all
your twilight zone Ray Bradbury Friday
the 13th of series voodoo crap magic no
need to sell your soul or deal with a
debilitating curse to get what you want
you get to keep the powers with science
there are no mystical repercussions for
messing with the perceived order of
things you can have your cake and eat it
too just as science demystifies religion
by exposing magic and miracles as either
sleight of hand or mere statistical
coincidence does evil exist and if so
can one detect and measure it Oh
rhetorical question Morty the answer is
yes you just have to be a genius Rick
demystifies the deal with the devil
trope has nothing more than a paranoid
fairy tale what these stories often
portray as too good to be true it's
usually just shorthand for don't
circumvent God's rules which is the
preferred pastime of every scientist
scientifically traditions are an idiot
thing with science Rick renders the
devil obsolete that's the real lesson
here evil isn't what should horrify us
any more karmic retribution is kind of
calming evildoers will eventually face
cosmic justice a world without this is
scary in its own right and while the
devil may be terrifying
if you want to find something really
scary you need to look beyond evil and
take a look at pure disinterested
science or as the devil puts it I may be
the devil but your grandpa is the devil
resistance is futile in auto-erotic
assimilation rick and morty takes
popular fears of conformity to criticize
our basic values and explore Rick's
inner psyche in the episode Rick runs
into his ex-girlfriend unity' who
assimilates alien races into her hive
mind collective by puking into their
mouths
it's a reference to the 1956 film
invasion of the Body Snatchers although
the idea of aliens turning us into some
sort of zombie collective has become a
familiar trope in science fiction
invasion of the Body Snatchers is about
an alien assault that replaces people
with creepy emotionless replicas of
themselves
similar to unities assimilated subjects
invasion of the Body Snatchers has
been read by many film critics as a
commentary on the then impending threat
of the Soviet Union and the loss of
individualism under communist rule and
you'll reborn into an untroubled world
where everyone's the same exactly what a
world
one way Rick and Morty inverts the body
snatchers story is by demonstrating that
the freedom we associate with
individualism can actually kind of suck
whereas the invasion of the body
snatchers projects an anxiety about
communism destroying individualism Rick
and Morty shows us the very not
fictional horrors of our own freedoms
Stephen set yourself free summer before
I took over this planet this man was a
registered sex offender the denizens of
unities Planet recalled their previous
lives as sex offenders and drug addicts
and their liberation from the collective
whole sparks a nipple driven race war I
didn't know freedom meant people doing
stuff that sucks this tension between
individual freedom and a collective
existence further develops Rick's
character see I've I've reconnected with
my family right after all being a part
of a family or in a relationship is
really about compromising your
individual freedoms for the good of the
group what if you did it for me what if
you came with us as a favor to us
because you loved us what Tim Phi
throughout the entire series Rick's
rampant egotism impedes his relationship
with his family
likewise in auto-erotic assimilation
Rick's egotism not only destroys his
relationship with unity but her entire
society
I think unity is great and you're a
horrible influence on it and of course
in unities letter to Rick it's actually
Rick who makes unity lose her sense of
self in their relationship I'm sure
there's no perfect version of me I'm
sure I'll just unify species after
species and never really be complete as
a bonus the show on TV is a recreation
of community Dan Harmon's show before
Rick and Morty now make them all make
fun of the blonde one now make them all
do it on the table now cancel it I'm
gonna put it back on haha its main
character Jeff Winger is like Rick also
an egotistical [ __ ] trying to make
sense of what it means to be around
people who care about it
5 5 I go ahead mock me
penis is evil the 1974 film Zardoz is
one of the more obscure references to
play a prominent role in the show if
you've been exposed to Zardoz it's
likely through an internet main Sean
Connery wearing this or giant floating
head vomiting up guns saying Rick and
Morty is in some ways thematically
similar to Zardoz and uses the film as a
basis for the episode raising
gazorpazorp in Zardoz a giant floating
head god commands some chosen savages to
go murder the rest of the savages one of
these chosen savages Zedd discovers his
giant floating head God is a lie and
that it was all some convoluted plan to
enslave the savages in service of some
immortal aristocrats
well obviously summer it appears the
lower tier of this society is being
manipulated through sex and advanced
technology by a hidden ruling class
sound familiar
raisin gazorpazorp takes the plot and
changes a few details
the conflict between immortals and
savages is replaced by men and women the
penis is still evil what are you in for
because I got I got a big you know penis
between my legs but it's all
precipitated because Morty wants a sex
doll the Zardoz reference follows up on
a general theme of atheism in the show
in this tale I am a fake God by
occupation Zardoz is a movie about a guy
who discovers his God as a lie and
proceeds to kill that God Rick and Morty
is a show reminding us that either there
is no God there is no God in your face
or that God isn't all that great that's
never existed all Rick's are created
equal but some are more equal than
others the episode lawnmower dog borrows
its title from the 1992 film lawnmower
man a movie about a dumb gardener who's
turned into a crazy genius by Pierce
Brosnan a lawnmower dog Rick makes the
family pooch snuffles smart enough to
stop peeing on the rug but by accident
also smart enough to subjugate the
entire human race snuffles rejects his
slave name in favor of snowball snuffles
do not call me
snuffles was my slave name you shall now
call me snowball a reference to the pig
and Leon Trotsky stand-in from George
Orwell's Animal Farm
snowball seems to be a pretty popular
name for revolutionary animals these
days as the antagonist of secret life of
pets also shares the name the
interspecies war that transpires in Rick
and Morty is similar to the war waged by
the creatures of Animal Farm against
their human masters whereas the farm
animals are bell against their labor
being exploited by lazy humans snuffles
repels against the lazy life of pet hood
you will walk when it is time to walk in
the book the rebellious animal slowly
turn into the farmers that they had
fought against the final scene shows
pigs standing on two feet and wearing
clothes completing the transformation
into their former overlords in Rick and
Morty with the help of inception it's
just like that movie that you keep
crowing about talking about inception
that's right Morty this is gonna be a
lot like that except you know it's gonna
move it makes sense a dystopian
nightmare is averted when snowball
realizes he's slowly turning into
everything he hated about humanity
taking over the humans world will lead
to nothing but more heartbreak more
cruelty the episode also makes a few
references to dog world a series concept
developed by Show co-creator Justin
roiland it features a family who gets
transported to an alternate dimension
where the world is run by dogs the pet
human is named ruffles which Rick
mistakenly called snuffles in lawnmower
dog all right ruffles what's his name
snuffles also at the end of the episode
when the dogs leave to populate the new
dimension Rick makes a smooth pitch for
the development of dog world as its own
show I think it'll be great Morty you
know it's good it could be developed
into a very satisfying project for
people of all ages
I mean I'd watch it morty for at least
11 minutes a pop destroying your
childhood there are too many references
to fairy tales science fiction and
horror to lists but many of them further
this idea of disillusionment central to
the show when the show isn't
deconstructing mysticism with hard
science I'm dropping to my knees and
pledging my eternal soul to the thing
that literally controls the in whether
it's deconstructing fantasies by
subjecting them to the mundanity of
everyday life meeseeks and destroy' is
the most overt example of this Mordy
brings rick on a cliche fairy tale
adventure raising money for poor
by playing out the story from Jack in
the Beanstalk to summarize the fairy
tale a boy Rob's a giant unprovoked
kills him and lives his life happily
ever after with his stolen riches
without suffering any consequences the
show normalizes the fairy tale by
subjecting it to a level of realism
usually omitted from children's stories
dispelling the cheery optimism that
comforted you as a child instead of
ending the story with some [ __ ]
about happily ever after
Morty is put on trial for his senseless
murder and confronted with the
emotionally devastated widow of the
Giants also The Villages King turns out
to be a sexual predator in another
episode were introduced to scary Terry a
legally safe knock off a Freddy Krueger
from a Nightmare on Elm Street while
scary Terry may seem terrifying with his
ability to murder you in your dreams and
all his life is utterly banal the show
dispels the horror of Freddy Krueger
with the same kind of normalization the
tormentor of dreams as it turns out as
the same shitty home life as the rest of
us back rich and is scared of the same
lame dreams anatomy Park is a reference
to both Jurassic Park and Fantastic
Voyage
Rick and Morty shows that the human body
which is often portrayed by movies like
Fantastic Voyage as a wonder of the
natural world anything like this it's
just a gonorrhea infested nightmare
if there's one humorous device that Rick
and Morty uses more than any other it's
robbing fantasy of its magic it
trivializes everything nothing you do
matters your existence is a lie not only
fairy tales but family love and even
life hey guys thanks for watching this
is a new kind of video for us so if you
liked it and want to see more make sure
to tell us in the comments below
and if you love Rick and Morty as much
as we do jump through this dimensional
portal to visit our friend Matt Pat at
the film theorist he's got a video
explaining the cliffhanger at the end of
Rick and Morty season 2 sure Rick's an
intergalactic prison now but do you know
why the show left some pretty
interesting clues as to what really
makes Rick a wanted man and it's not
what you might think so jump through
this portal to visit the film theorist
and find out and to make sure you don't
miss our upcoming wisecrack videos click
here to be taken to our channel page
where you can watch another video and
subscribe thanks for watching guys for
our next video I've got to tap into the
dark side squanch you later